a mother teaching her daughter to say
that her ex raped her
with Rika he's mean and you don't like
him did I do that you don't [__] with
him did I do that do you hear me he
touched you
yes he did
hey
yep no look at she was so
you got your own camera what this is a
man that [__] with you Rico you need and
you don't like him did I do that you
don't [__] with him with him did I do
that can you hear me he touched you
yes he did and this is what we don't
talk about again women and guys I'm I'm
saying this to help you understand it
women we're emotions first we're logic
second we don't think about consequences
we don't think about anyone else we just
process everything through us so what
she's doing is she's so pissed she's so
mad she she'll go to any lengths
to really destroy this man and this is
so common I've seen videos of of men
getting
beat up and killed by other men because
a woman told a story
you know and I I think the men and
women's lives really should question
them they really need to see evidence
before they just believe a chick you
know a woman can be good in your eyes
and seem all right in your eyes and
maybe in your life she's nice to you but
that doesn't mean she's trustworthy and
most women aren't credible there's a
reason why in religions like Islam they
have two women Witnesses because they
know I don't even think we fully see
reality a lot of times when we have
these emotions and that's at least once
a month
um and the problem is women like her
have had no consequence for anything
we've never seen women get consequences
so we don't think twice before doing
this stuff
and this is why I would argue you know
men raise better children so we really
need to default custody to the men I
don't understand why women get custody
when we we see women are typically chaos
men are typically more order
um so why do we trust women to raise the
kids when really the men should be
defaults especially when the women are
the ones leaving
so and and you see this trend of a lack
of consequences in society and what that
leads to for women so I'm going to give
you guys an example
um the woman that I covered last episode
that had a brick thrown at her face
right so and I I got some pushback I saw
the other day on this so essentially
this woman came out and said that men
were not protecting her and that she got
this brick thrown at her face and the
the men were wrong like why wouldn't
they protect her and this man
um didn't she didn't give him her number
and that's why he did it and then you
know I covered it and we see more
evidence come forward of
this woman having a history of
instigating stuff you know she was
walking around hitting white people
for no reason she was out twerking on
the streets she's a single mother she's
on drugs like guys this stuff is
supposed to come into account when
assessing The credibility of a witness
yes it matters no it's not just about
that specific instance we are building a
character a reputation and looking at
her character to see is this a credible
a credible person so not only did
everybody give her attention in sympathy
she raised 42 000
from people probably women were idiots
um you know to fix her face or whatever
the hell she needed it that 42 cap
and you know
um look look at look at what comes out
yo this man just hit me and my face with
a brick and all these black men just
once and they don't give up
doesn't matter hit me it would rather
Rock and it hit me in my face if I were
to give her my number
her friend her friend this time is
raising money on behalf of so she didn't
made forty thousand on the first one and
now they're creating another one with
Mario but a different different person
allegedly but they saying that they're
all friends with rope a yellow brick
roller so y'all have been full here's a
[__] GoFundMe a fourth GoFundMe that
they just put up and y'all believe that
this is real y'all really believe this
is real y'all are stupid
stupid
first thing I thought was that it didn't
make any sense
from people
bricks hitting people especially her
saying that a man wanted her number and
she got the brick because she didn't
want to give him her number it just
wasn't adding up
acting like somebody did her something
when no one touched her at all she
literally already had her face like that
wore a mask and then took it off right
before filming this video and later on
we'll get into the account from the
nurse who claimed that she put that
stuff in her own face and had it drained
at a clinic but she snatched the mask
off and then ran over in front of some
guys acting like somebody did something
to her immediately the men who are
supposed to be Somali men are just
standing around like what do you want me
to do that's because she ran from across
the street putting on this whole victim
show it was unbelievable but
unbelievably all these people believed
her
so first of all shout out to Pink book
lessons really great YouTube channel she
does a good job of covering this type of
stuff
um yeah and I think really she broke it
down perfectly
um so not only this woman had four
gofundme's she's done an incident like
this before the nurse is now saying she
was lying old friends have come out and
said that she just does stuff like this
and the guys didn't see the incident and
there wasn't any surveillance footage
and this is my thing guys we cannot just
keep coming to the aid of women because
they cry and whine this is what has
gotten us into trouble in the first
place us voting like this is what
happens women cry and we whine and we
know we have this like power over men
um you know this is clearly conscious I
don't think every time women do it it's
a conscious thing but it's it's like the
these events keep popping up where women
literally make [__] up like you can't
even say this wasn't intentional or
planned
um I mean it's probably obviously poorly
like at least get an actor to hit you or
something you know what I mean like if
you're gonna commit commit you know but
you know and and this is my problem is
we we throw money at people because of
sympathy and it's just another way of
doing propaganda basically these women
playing victim and then everyone's oh no
and then the solution is throw money or
sympathy or attention Adam and boom now
we got a bunch of crazy batshit women
and I I think we just needed to start
Guy saying some general things about
female nature that are you know and it's
unfortunate because a lot of these that
I'm I bring up aren't positive
but I mean look at Society right now
like it's really crumbling because we
don't acknowledge the way women are and
I really think it does it does a
disservice on both sides because women
are never told the truth their whole
life and we're told we're so amazing and
special and everything we say is correct
and then the men are discriminated
against it's just it everything's out of
whack
um so
you know and one of those things is that
women shouldn't be in these hard jobs
and we have women lying about this stuff
we don't need women lying about Men At
Work